when I was growing up people would say I
wasn't black enough you know or that I
don't talk back and I said well I'm
talking and I'm black ergo no maybe
brothers shouldn't say ergo
[Music]
hey hey and welcome this is the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special I'm excited
to welcome to the show Larry Wilmore who
you will remember from the nightly show
on Comedy Central and also the Larry
Wilmore podcast black on the air he's
also the creator of shows including
blackish the co-creator of insecure on
HBO we get to all of that in just a
moment but first I know you don't want
to think about your impending death no
one wants to think about that stuff and
so you procrastinate and usually
procrastination is a bad thing but life
isn't quite so black and white sometimes
procrastination can work in your favor
for example if you need a life insurance
but you've been putting it off
congratulations to you you have managed
to procrastinate long enough for
technology to make it easy policy genius
is the easy way to shop for insurance
online in just two minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers and
find your best price once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape no sales
pressure no hidden fees just financial
protection and peace of mind and policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they can also help you find the
right home insurance and auto insurance
and disability insurance so if you need
life insurance but you've been busy
doing literally anything else because
why would you think about death
check out policy genius it's the easy
way to compare all the top insurers and
find the best value for you policy
genius com nobody wants to shop for a
life insurance which is why they made it
easy go check them out at policy
genius.com be an adult make sure your
family is taken care of in case god
forbid something should happen to you go
check them out at policy genius.com all
right Larry
thanks so much for stopping by I really
appreciate it thanks man it's nice to be
here I got to say I'm super excited
about having you because thanks you know
it's rare to have somebody who I know we
don't share politics on some of these
matters and and it'll be interesting to
discuss that but it's really important I
think to have these interesting and
civil conversations and I really dig it
dude I couldn't agree more and thanks
for agreeing to be on my podcast - yeah
for sure I'm really looking forward to I
think it's kind of like a prisoner
exchange well we're both walking across
the bridge that's how this goes you make
sure it's a prisoner so I mean Munoz
will have so I work prisoners for a
reason a lot of people don't acknowledge
they've heard of it so I want to start
by asking you for it for folks who well
first I start with an apology so I will
say that back in 2016 I saw one of your
bits on the nightly show and it pissed
me off and I said that and I said they
remember which one it was I'm trying to
remember
you probably shouldn't yeah now you can
find on YouTube I'm sure and I
said something about you not being funny
and it's not true facts don't care about
my feelings as it turns out you know yes
look but but it's okay if it didn't make
you laugh though
that's is it it absolutely okay so I'm
not racist if it didn't make me well
races the whole difference
yes it's races if you don't laugh okay I
just I want to make sure yeah but you're
not races if you don't think I'm funny
okay well I do think you're funny so
that's the big start with this I mean
for folks you don't know how you got
into the Hollywood business and what
kind of where you come from what's your
background well my background it's funny
um a lot of people ask how I got into
comedy and I say really I got into
showbiz I could get comedy out of me
like I was cracking jokes on school you
know making people laugh and that sort
of thing and and I had a pivotal moment
when I was in college trying to figure
out what I wanted to do because at that
time my parents were divorced and you
know my mom raised six kids and I was I
was a really good student and the kind
of promise for me it seemed like to go
the academic ground and really you know
go more traditional route to have
something solid as they say to fall back
and I had a lot of pressure for that
because I mean we really didn't have any
money or anything and that type of thing
but I knew I really loved showbiz and
comedy in that kind of stuff but I
really didn't know what that was at the
time and I came from a big sports
neighborhood too and there were a lot of
people they played professional sports
and I saw that it was possible to go
from this to that
you know into something but in college I
saw bookstore to go I had an amazing
summer where I went into a lot of
people's houses and I saw so many people
that seem like they were unhappy with
their choices and I thought you know
Larry at the end of the day just do what
makes you happy you know and I decided
to just go into showbiz and I started as
a stand-up comedian and as an actor and
the reason why I like stand-up comedy
because I got to write my own material
and you got to perform an actor was very
frustrating because you had to wait for
auditions all the time and that kind of
stuff
but I was had kind of an entrepreneurial
attitude towards my act you know always
thought that it's my business you know
I'm gonna run my business in that type
of way and I've always kept that
attitude and I've always shifted over
the years but I always liked making
people laugh that was the first love and
I've done different things along the way
there kind of expressed it in a in a
different way for instance when I
understand comic I be do stand-up comedy
make people laugh that way but after a
while I noticed that I wasn't getting
cast in roles because they
and fit a certain Hollywood type that
was what they caught the urban type you
know there was a movie called Hollywood
shuffle you're a little too young to
remember that but uh Keenan Keenan Ivory
Wayans and Robert Townsend made a movie
about how being in Hollywood and getting
typecast in that kind of stuff and they
were on it
the actress to be more like Murph phonic
like Eddie Murphy or streetwise and that
type of thing and I was kind of a you
know political comic I did satirical
things I did silly jokes my act was a
hodgepodge of things but it wasn't what
you would call a street act you know and
by that I meant I mean like seeming like
you come from the ghetto that's your
point of view you know you have that
language
I didn't sound like that so it was hard
for me to get into doors with people
that were hiring then because it's in my
colleague was focusing on that so I
decided to become a writer at that point
and kind of take control of my career so
I kind of transitioned from being just a
stand-up comic to writing on TV shows in
Hollywood and that really started my
long career of writing and producing so
my evil little plan was to one day
create my own TV show
it ended up happening - so what do you
think Hollywood's relationship is with
black folks because obviously you talked
a little bit about that right there you
know how do you think that's changed
over time because I don't think we have
the time to go through Hollywood has had
an interesting relationship with black I
don't know how far we're gonna go we can
go back but in my time let's say there
was the black ceiling that's you know
and what that is it's hard to describe
there was there's a there are a lot of
different ways that Hollywood likes to
pigeonhole you and I always said that
the color that Hollywood likes the most
is green you know as long as you can
make green the pigeonholing goes away
and they just want you to do more of
that you know but one of the resistances
that I found as a writer was there was
an opinion in Hollywood that if you're a
black writer you weren't as good as the
white writers and I this was an opinion
that I've kind of fought against over
the years by trying to create shows and
opportunities for people who I've been
on the board of directors for the
writers skill and and I've seen it
firsthand
now that's an opinion that is that you
know it wasn't held by Hollywood alone
but it was certainly opinion in there
that as a writer who was back we had to
fight that type of thing
you know so you know Hollywood has
always had you know that kind of
relationship I guess well now obviously
you've got a couple of successful shows
on the air and they deal largely with
racial matters in a pretty complex way
in a really interesting way I'm more
familiar with with blackish than I am
with insecurity now blackish I didn't
co-create but I did help launch it right
I produced the pilot with Kenya and
helped run part of the first season so I
mean the shows that you are involved
with I think at least heavily our shows
that they do have kind of an interesting
take on black identity that's that's I
think different from a lot of what
Hollywood has been pushing for years so
I wanted to ask you about that well when
you talk about race in America and sort
of where we stand at this point I mean
it's a broad question but where do you
think we stand in America on race it
seems to me I can give you my theory
which is I think I think we were better
off ten years ago on race when Barack
Obama was first elected it feels like
things have gone in the wrong direction
as far as racial polarization in the
country but you know well I'd love to
get your take on it
well racial polarization is a very
specific term you know as opposed to
racism or racial relations or that type
of thing
I think racial polarization can be
attributed to more racial issues are in
our face in everyone's face as opposed
to just in our face maybe you know I
think a lot of I think what caused a lot
of issues to come up our smartphones
believe it or not you know people were
able to videotape many things and and
social media or people able to share
more things than normally we could share
and I think more people became aware of
things that were happening and at the
same time people could express
themselves in ways that they normally
couldn't express you know whether it was
through anger or through hyperbole or
whatever it was you know and I think
that's had more to do with it I don't
think the racial situation in America
has changed over the last 10 years I
think people are more aware of how of
how it expresses itself you know like
for instance I'll give an example
like many people think the relationship
with blacks and police have gotten worse
and I will argue that what has gotten
more apparent as people's ability to see
what it is because many I think many
people in America when they see a story
a bad story about blacks and police they
look at it as a story I'm for the merits
of
that story and who's right and who's
wrong and the most people kind of view
it in that box which is fair way to view
it
blacks don't look at it as as a story
they see it as another chapter in the
long in the book in a large book of the
history of police abuse on black people
so whether that's fair or not it's kind
of how its viewed so many times when an
incident between blacks and police gets
reported and by the way many of them are
reported now the one were before I don't
know if the number has gotten larger or
smaller it's hard to know that but I do
think the reportage of it has gotten
larger so it makes it seem like the
numbers larger and that's a whole
different issue right because um now
when blacks get to see more of that to
them it's almost like confirmation bias
you know it's confirming this long story
that that you already know about so
that's how kind of the different
experiences
I think occur and why people kind of
have a disconnect sometimes and not
being able to relate to what the actual
black experience in America is in
relationship to cops and I say that as a
child if someone who's in law
enforcement my father was probation
officers at LA County Sheriff's you know
and like I don't have any animosity
towards police of that type of thing but
I am keenly aware of that relationship
well I mean speaking about that
particularly I think that this would be
an interesting area to talk about
various to talk to a comedy writer I
know so you know yeah let's do some of
the serious stuff and then I want to get
to the comedy world because whatever
there's a lot there but you know the
with relation to that you know my view
was that when when President Obama came
into office and you're you're a big
exponent of President Obama's obviously
when he came into office I felt like
even for me I opposed him I didn't want
him to be President to the United States
I didn't think he was qualified his
politics were not my politics but one of
the things that that I felt that I think
most Americans felt was that this could
have been a moment of reconciliation
that was one of the messages she seemed
to be promoting you know for good or ill
in 2008 2009 when he was running for
office and then instead it seemed like
he was range
I mean exactly and then he sort of
reverted in 2012 particularly to a more
polarizing rhetoric with regard to sort
of these these incidents and you know
now I'm thinking well forward to
Ferguson and Baltimore and trying to
take specific instances and anecdotes
and then try to draw a broad narrative
from those those instances and act oh so
you contrasted
the the the view that many people in the
United States have a police incident you
look at in isolation you see how it goes
down with the head of broader black view
of okay this confirms priors about
what's about relationship right exactly
and I wonder if the country would be
better off not to discount the narrative
completely because obviously there is
that history there but would we be
better off on an anecdotal basis
actually looking at the facts of the
case and trying to do that in isolation
to a certain extent well you guys what
would be better off as an interesting
question there's a lot of what we'd be
better off doing what I don't know you
know I think by a case-by-case basis is
the is the best way to look at it and
see how we should judge a certain thing
and I'll give an example like I thought
I particularly thought that Obama was
out of line getting a vote on that whole
Henry gates thing like to me
stop it Obama command Henry gates got
locked out of his house
you do not need to have beer with
anybody what are you proving I even
mocked it on The Daily Show at the time
you know because I thought it was
ridiculous that is not about for
preparing anything it's a whatever that
was it was a mistake whatever it was but
nobody's trying to lock Henry gates up
for or that type of thing you know at
least I didn't think so or at least what
happened with Henry gates to me doesn't
talk about a current problem in America
you know that to me is one incident that
happened then it's more anecdotal now
the Trayvon Martin thing was a different
case
you know Trayvon Martin thing was very
problematic on many different levels and
I was fascinated that sides were taken
in that that were our typical political
ideological sides like how is this
happening why why is this a political
situation you know I really couldn't
understand that I did fill Obama may
have overstepped when he said if I had a
son it would have been like Trayvon but
I didn't think his his emotions there
and his intent was overstepping you know
because it was an event that was
polarizing America and America was
discussing so you know as the head of
the country I didn't think he was out of
line and discussing that you know but
that to me is another one of those
incidents that black that were related
to differently you know no question and
when I came down there were polls and it
was really fascinating where was like a
huge majority of lack of thought this
was a racist killing and basically what
white folks thought that it was the
most of the polls said we need more
information to come in and then the
Obama DOJ obviously came out and said
that it was not at least there's no
evidence that it was a racist killing
the media coverage was was in my view
very skewed in one direction in that
particular debate but yeah well and for
blacks we don't need media coverage you
know we just have it's hard to explain
sometimes because we just have a
different experience of it from the
beginning and one of the things that
tough is for me when I see these things
especially as a father now is that the
fact that this that he is not an adult
and that he was a minor gets thrown out
right away and blacks for for many years
in history it didn't matter what age you
were you were treated just like you were
an adult you know and you know and treat
it like you're some animal or that type
of thing or something to be feared and
it felt to me that Trayvon Martin and I
don't know much about the kid really
about his life or anything but that
immediately he was automatically to be
feared more even than a southern person
who had a gun like this kid with
skittles was to be feared more than this
guy who had a gun and that is the type
of stuff that makes my head explode and
how can you have a gun and you're afraid
of this person that is unarmed those
type of situations I think makes
people's head explode around that type
of thing so in a second I want to ask
you about you know the the 2016 White
House press Pro respondents dinner they
did because obvious that was a real high
button I made everybody mad yeah you did
you succeed I'll get to that in just one
second but first the big tech companies
they're interested in your data they
just love it your data and they're
making all sorts of money off your did
it well why shouldn't you make money off
your data big token is a new app that
lets you share data about yourself your
interest your habits and then get paid
for it right now you share an enormous
amounts of information with tech
companies and they're making money off
of you
so should you that's where big token
comes in here's how it works first you
download the app and you sign up for a
free big token account next you complete
actions to earn points actions include
answering surveys checking into
locations connecting your social
accounts and more then you can redeem
your points for award it's like cash and
gift cards or you could donate your
earnings to charity if you're that kind
of person
you choose what data you share with big
token and then you get paid for it
you can also get more points for
referring friends and family your data
is always secured in big token if you
want to start earning money for your
data
the App Store or Google Play search for
big token b.i.g Tok en that is one word
download the app and sign up make sure
to use my referral code ben shapiro
that's my name
again search big token in the App Store
or Google Play download the app use my
referral code ben shapiro to sign up
claim it your data and get paid so i
want to talk about the the White House
Correspondents Dinner I have a feeling
that when you and I talked on your
podcast the Travon stuff may come up a
little bit more possible and but it is
it's a really interesting topic but I I
know we only have an hour so I want to
move through some material but everyone
so the White House Correspondents Dinner
event there there are a couple things
that jumped out at me that I want to ask
you about so the first one was obviously
the big comment was he's saying that
Barack Obama was your n-word yeah now
what everybody jumped on in the media
was the use of the n-word that I found
entirely non-controversial to the extent
that it seemed like you were making a
joke right joke I assume is a joke I do
want to get your kind of general take on
it written bunch of comedy skits
basically about the use of the n-word
yes appropriating one it's not you wrote
your book about when it's appropriate
but it's not except the whole
deconstruction that in fact John Oliver
and I did a whole piece of end of the
daily show right does the councilman who
wanted to ban in and we just tortured
him but what's interesting is that and
it I even had a back person asked me not
long ago he said do you ever get me
follow when you called the president the
n-word you know I'm doing impression of
him right now and I said well I didn't
call him the n-word you know I didn't
say you know and the president uh n-word
you know like I didn't say that I'm
cleaning it up for Ben's uh for my sense
of my sensibilities I'm painting like I
said you know it was partly a joke but
it actually was a tribute in many ways
and this was the part that a lot of
people didn't understand but the people
who got it really understood I wanted to
have a moment with Obama that was kind
of past a joke and the moment started
when I was talking about because I'm the
same age as Obama and he's done a little
bit better but what are you gonna do you
know he'll do that whole president thing
whatever but when we were you know when
we were born we were born into a
segregated world you know both of us you
know and when I was a kid a black man
couldn't be the quarterback of a
football team I mean that's just reality
you know like I said no way we're gonna
follow a black
person you know in almost any aspects of
Sam couldn't be the quarterback of a
football team and for me the emotional
weight of the fact that that a black man
could now be the leader of the free
world was almost overwhelming fact when
I wrote that I was crying you know just
just the realization of that journey
knowing that that was his actual journey
and so I wanted to express that to him
and then the colloquial way that I
wanted to do it was to kind of have a
private-public moment in acting we
called that public solitude you know
where it was kind of a almost a personal
cultural moment to that and I knew it
was gonna be controversy and I almost
didn't do it and I tried to talk myself
out of it and and the people who I chose
said no Larry you have to get up there
what are you guys trying to do to me so
I was concerned about it actually but I
thought you know I go ahead and do it
and I have to tell you in during the the
correspondence there I absolutely was
keenly aware that the whole room had
turned on me you know that it wasn't
going well and it's a tough room but
still I did a joke in the beginning that
didn't go too well and you could just
filming as a comedy can fill in the room
turns on you where they're not giving
you the benefit of thinking that you're
funny they're now they're giving me the
benefit of no MF you've got to prove
that to us you know we're just gonna mmm
we're just gonna see you know and I
think I said something horrible it's who
you know and you know I think that I
lost I don't any to me I'm thinking
great the wolf blitzer joke lost the
river great but that was the other thing
I didn't mind going after CNN and MSNBC
and think I was probably the lightest on
fox news you know I actually had kind of
a fun joke about megyn kelly you know
about I think come on Becky with the
good hair something like that you know
but um so so you could feel it that they
just were not having this at all so in
the middle of the egg then I swear to
you I'm thinking you know what screw
this I'm gonna do this you know I almost
skipped over it but in the middle of it
did it and Obama immediately got up and
he kind of embraced me and I was like
poof you know I think that he liked it I
wasn't sure you know I'm still not sure
how the First Lady pout about it but but
both the black intelligentsia I'll say I
coat the black arathi I have a harsher
word biotin arena
a more inappropriate term really came
out against me
people like caper Ryan I think CNN so
people in there I think Van Jones said
I've never been a show Larry one more so
soon people were saying that stuff you
know
um van and I have since appeared
together and a lot of maybe older
establishment black people and many
people on the left to just really
slammed it and did not like it at all
but a lot of younger people and I
because I got a lot of attention of
course of mine loved it inside as they
said that was the blackest thing I've
ever seen but some people said and some
people saw it as um just really saying
something that no one ever says and
saying in a way that they understood you
know and they appreciated the fact that
I went after everybody and the other
part you know and I thought I'd really
bombed afterwards I thought oh my career
is over everything's wrong you know and
then you know much after that I just you
know didn't worry about it too much but
Obama brought me up in his speech to
Howard University which was very nice by
the way Obama was very nice about it he
was very kind because he didn't have to
be you know the president can easily
throw people under the bus
hardly doing anything at all and he went
out of so you say and as Larry Wilmore
said I was watching TV says Larry
Wilmore said I'm a cop is he gonna say
that you murdered he said uh you know
when I was born a black man couldn't be
a quarterback so he just said I was
saying huh what I wanted he was there
but it was very nice about it I mean the
part of the of the routine that I
critiques I remember doing this on my
show was it was the part where you
talked about you didn't care about his
policy as long as he's still black he's
with you exactly and that was the part
where I said you know if that is the
actual perspective then I got a problem
with that obviously because you know if
you're just talking about sure he's
black there for like I don't even think
you believe that obviously right I don't
think that if Herman Cain had been
running in 2008 you probably wouldn't
voted for Herman yeah but I would have
voted for compound in 2000 in fact I
wanted to support compound 2000 but you
know I also like Colin Powell but here's
what I mean obviously part of it is a
joke now because I'm a Democrat
I am predisposed to voting for a
Democrat so all he needed to be who's
black in a moment for me in terms of the
qualified Democrats so that's the
threshold not that any black person
that's the part for humor right
of
you know that's not to lecture you about
a joke or anything like that but um but
and I'm not here to like really oh no no
no I yeah I know but but yeah some
people take it completely literal and
think well the black pizza man can be I
can't be president long as he's black
Larry vote for him but to me what the
meaning is behind the joke is how much
that really meant to me in that moment
you know and that Obama didn't have to
over prove everything like that was
enough for me for that election but then
the rest of the joke that I said and I
don't know if I said it that night I
said now the next brother he's gonna
have to prove something to me
that was always the second part of that
joke you know I don't know if I said
that night but yeah I was speaking the
joke speaks more to how I really feel
historically about Obama's election so
that says less about Obama than it does
sort of how you believe America has
treated the possibility of a black
president it sounds like because I think
people would have vote for Colin Powell
I agree with you I mean I think everyone
in 2000 in 2000 they would have voted
for him I think his wife was afraid of
it and I think people were exhausted by
the Clinton years a bit and he's kind of
Lisa rice ran for president today she
could be President I don't know I don't
know if she has the political talent to
do I think you know she has the hef to
do it but president the presidency as
we've learned my observation of it it
takes so much political talent to cut
through all the people but you know you
never know so one of the things that
you've written extensively about Ann on
your shows you talk a lot about black
identity and I mean your show it's
called black on the air so that raises
some really interesting questions about
how how should Americans view black
identity like when I think Jewish
identity I know that breaks down and in
several different ways the one that
people usually use is Jewish ethnicity
which is one I actually don't care about
as a religious Jew I don't care if
you're Jewish
ethnically I don't care whether you eat
matzo balls or something as a religious
Jew I care about the religious aspect um
but when it comes to black identity how
does that how does that break down it
seems like a lot of the shows that
you've worked on sort of struggle with
with what is what is is there such thing
as black enough or not black enough or
well it is a multi-layered question
because it's something that is a
question that blacks have within
themselves to you know my parents are
from Chicago and you know they
experience a lot of different types of
racial incidents and racism or whatever
but a lot of it comes from within the
black community and during even as back
of the slave days there's something
called the paper bag test where you
to be you couldn't be darker than a per
bag to beacons because the idea was to
be white you know so the closer you look
like that the better it was for you this
was an idea that blacks had back then
too there's a lot of people forget about
that so there's always been kind of a an
interest struggle I think Spike Lee
talked about this little school days but
I could be wrong about that between what
are called light-skinned blacks and
darker skinned blacks you know and
there's a lot of opinions about that you
know and those opinions are still in
there somewhere you know some ballots
some invalid you know and black identity
I used to make jokes about this all the
time where I said when I was growing up
people would say I wasn't black enough
you know or that I don't talk black and
I said well I'm talking and I'm black
ergo I may be brothers shouldn't say
ergo and in fact I did a bit early in my
in my stand-up career where I had this
product called black away we could put
in your mouth and take the black out of
your voice you know so you could do job
interviews of a phone and that kind of
yes black away works right at the mouth
so I've always struggled with the idea
black identity myself I've never liked
sometimes what people think is black
identity is a cultural thing like tied
to how you speak you know the clothes
you wear and they're these questions
about Obama early on it's ridiculous you
know and I said Martin Luther King
didn't say yo yo yo mum she didn't talk
like that but you know he was black
there's no there's no mistaken man you
know so black identities had some some
cultural views about it that aren't
quite accurate but people own that
feeling that that's with blackness is
but blackness to me means so many
different things and it's tough it's
been said more eloquently than I've ever
said it by many poets and people on
years people from James Baldwin to Toni
Morrison 12 or so all sorts of people
right but um so I think it has a meaning
that is very much tied to the the
journey of black people in America and
that's what makes being black a black
American different from being black
anywhere else in the world I think and
it's hard to quantify from a specific
cultural point of view because there's
not a direct lying to a place you know
in a place with the specific
sure so I can't trace my ancestors back
to a town in Italy where there's a
specific culture that's Italian and that
type of thing
you know blacks were kind of strict to
that so that's why there's a lot of
discussion about what black identity is
because you know it has different
meanings for different people you know I
hope that kind know that it does and the
reason that I asked a little messy is
what it actually is
yeah and it's messy for blacks as well
you know it's not a clean black stone
always a granite like my mother will not
be called african-american Susan I'm not
from Africa hey girl you're right you
know well the reason that I ask is
because when the question that I didn't
ask at the beginning is how racist is
America like where are we on racism in
the real Americans race but the scale
from Thomas Jefferson to George
Jefferson on the Jefferson scale how
racism Andrew Jackson is Samuel Jackson
let's use the Jackson scale how racism I
say I'd say sometimes it's closer to and
Reuben Samuel the reason that the reason
I didn't ask that question at the
beginning sure is because I think that
the definition of racism sometimes seems
fuzzy itself sometimes sometimes I think
there's stuff that everybody sort of
clearly agrees is racist when people say
black folks are inferior who are racist
we can all agree it's like there's a
variant of pornography I'll know when I
see right exactly and and this does make
for some some weird and awkward
political conversations because very
often somebody will make a point that
they don't think is racist in any way
and then there and then immediately they
are labeled a racist by people who may
not be black maybe black its inner and
you know one of my views of the Trump
phenomenon is that there was a whole
swath of people in the middle of the
country who had been told by the media
that a lot of their critiques of America
were based on race and they were sick of
being lectured about that and here was
Trump and he would just didn't convince
Oprah and so all vote for him and there
was there there was a lot of kickback to
that so I guess I guess the question is
you know using your kind of you know
Potter Stewart Elmo and I see a
definition of racism how much how much
racism do you think is still endemic to
the United States I don't know I mean
I'm not you know I'm not that type of I
have no way of quantifying that at all
you know I'm not gonna ask you
percentages or something but yeah I mean
I guess that the reason that it comes up
in politics so much is because very
often people look at for example wealth
disparities between black folks and
white folks and obviously some of that
is the result of historic discrimination
from slavery to Jim Crow and then you
get politicians up there talking about
slavery reparations and people say well
I didn't enslave anybody and current
wealth inequalities income inequalities
forget wealth income inequalities those
seem largely driven by personal
decisions not by decisions made in the
past so well the the black let's call it
bottom class you know to me especially
when you look at the urban areas I'll
use that term in the cities where
there's ghettos and that type of thing
to me is a direct result of the Jim Crow
laws and the segregation and redlining
and that sort of stuff and there's two
reasons and that sort of inability to be
engaged in society some things that been
passed down for generations
unfortunately you know and by to be able
to participate in a way that is
reflective the way the rest of the
society can I'll say you know and it's
happening to front span which is kind of
interesting one front is the obvious one
you know of how blacks were kept out of
society in many different ways you know
much of which can't be talked about too
much because people either get tired of
it or they've or there's guilt or that
sort of thing but it is reality in this
country I remember a friend of mine
showing me an old deed from a house he
bought where it said can't sell to
blacks and that to me and Jews by the
way you know just put them in there but
that was written down you know it's one
thing for the collusion to be just you
know something that people don't say but
it's another thing you see it written
down and and much of what was kept
blacks out of society was written down
written into laws you know it was Plessy
versus Ferguson actually you know set up
the whole separate but equal which of
course is though doesn't even make sense
you know the the fact that you have to
make it separate means you don't feel
it's equal you know otherwise why are
you making except for it you know so
that was one aspect of it you know now
what's interesting is that many blacks
stur were able to thrive in that system
you know you have many doctors yeah you
know professional people people to start
with home businesses you know people
that yes that's what the black middle
class in the 50s is grass in the black
middle class or 70s the difference was
been they
lived in black communities and almost
strictly black communities now this is
one of the ironies of desegregation many
of them moved out of those neighborhoods
and out of those situations that leaves
you with the almost a permanent
underclass how many of those situations
so you had kind of almost a combination
of black fight and white flight that
happened over the same course of time
which many resources in the ability to
use your community which by the way
people under sell how important
communities are in helping people you
know get out of their situations you
know I mean Hillary Clinton was made fun
of for saying you know what is the
village long it takes you what's right
but it takes a village really has
meaning that I think both sides agree
with but because it was a political
statement people took jabs at it but
what it takes a village means is there's
many important parts of a community that
work in order to help people get out of
situations one of them is the home of
course but the extended community is
very important as well and I think a lot
of the the black community's lost some
of that support
unfortunately so it was almost a double
attack you know so in a second oh I want
to ask kind of your perspective on black
Republicans and and whether you know
they're ignoring that past or whether
they just have a different perspective
on how to get out of that going forward
but can we take just a quick break for a
quick word absolutely look here's the
deal you want to get in shape but it's
not just about losing weight it's about
learning healthier habits and feeling
better about yourself whether that's
more stamina to keep up with your busy
life finally getting into the gold jeans
or being more in tune with your body's
needs and practicing more self-care
listen I am a person I like to workout a
lot but that doesn't answer all of the
questions about how exactly to get in
shape
sometimes you need a habit-forming
change this is where numa comes in it's
a habit changing solution that helps
users learn to develop a new
relationship with food through
personalized courses based in psychology
Noom teaches you why you do the things
that you do and arms you with the tools
to break the bad habits and replace them
with better ones Newman is not a diet
it's a healthy easy to stick to way of
life which is what you need if you
actually want to change your life you
don't wanna be yo-yoing in and out of
diets you want to change your life by
changing your habits you don't have to
change it all in one day
small steps make big progress sign up
for your trial today at noon n oom
dot-com
Piro what do you have to lose visit new
Montcalm slash apparel and start your
trial today that is Noom calm / Pierrot
the last weight loss program you'll ever
need okay so given your view that it's
mostly kind of historic circumstance
that has created the black that is
responsible that gives one to me one of
the bigger reasons why it looks
different than any other part of society
you know part was the separation and the
part was the was the other separation
you know I mean so how do you view black
Republicans then so I know obviously a
lot of like Republicans those are the
circles in which I move and their view
from I don't want to sum up everybody's
view but it seems like their view is is
basically the same as a lot of
Republicans view which is okay so given
all these historical circumstances you
know have a group of people who are
living in poverty it's not unique to
black America to live in poverty you
have a lot of impoverished white folks
in Appalachia and the chief ways of
getting out of poverty are you go to
high school you finish high school you
don't have babies out of wedlock you
don't commit a crime you go get a job
and these are all things that presumably
are within rational bounds like you
should be able to do this if you if you
apply yourself
so perhaps government is creating an
incentive system that is actually
creating too much of a safety net for
making bad decisions particularly in
terms of single motherhood in the
welfare programs for example and so what
actually needs to happen is more
policing in inner cities to make sure
that property rights are respected and
businesses businesses can move in and
bring a tax base perhaps what we need
our stronger churches because we need
more people who are encouraged to get
married as opposed to having kids out of
wedlock that seems to be the perspective
of you know black Republicans like Larry
elder or Thomas so or do they also have
a cure for Appalachia I mean this is
this is and yet if very often if anybody
sort of says this sort of stuff then
there they are tarred with the yeah not
black enough or if you're black
Republican not black and I'm sure my
black Republican friends get that a lot
and if you're white then you say that
then it's you're racist because you're
not taking into account history enough I
think um you know notwithstanding all of
the points that you made which you are
correct though those are the points
said I wouldn't say black Republicans so
much as I would say black conservatives
I think yeah that's that's there I think
is more fair especially when you think
of someone like Thomas Lowe or someone
like that right Shelby Steele some of
these
who have written very eloquently about
some of these things you know I always
look at things from the historical point
of view as well it used to be the other
way around then which is interesting huh
I was working for Whoopi Goldberg once
on a show she's to have parties at house
Scrabble parties that type of thing and
I need to kick some butt let me just say
but Whoopi was a real collector of
things and there is this book called um
I think it's got the Negro handbook and
it was like from 1911 or something like
that and I was looking for and said do
you want that you can take it I'm like
oh really thinks and I took it and I
found it fascinating because it was a
snapshot of 1911 in the black experience
in 1911 and like one thing that was
devastating was like it listed the
number of lynchings that year I was like
poof just to having a book listing the
number like this was something that was
recorded you know I mean and to have
that book speaking to you now I was like
ah you know and it's almost like it's a
matter of fact type of thing you know
which was fascinating but it had
everything and there from black doctors
and people that were doing things but
there was just one letter that I found
very interesting and it was a letter to
two black americans imploring them not
to give other support to one party and
that they felt that this was a problem
and that party was the republican party
and it was this almost the same exact
speech that a black conservative would
make now to democratic party you know
and it's interesting that that black
political behavior is one of the more
interesting hard to figure out things
that me even as a public or junking
people who watch it can't always put my
finger on why obviously Republican
Lincoln freeing the slaves
makes sense Black's got Republicans
coming out of that for a long time you
know but I think blacks have been very
um what's right word may be collective
in how they've approached politics
almost like it's a team game in many
ways I think might be a fair way to put
it and if you look at the I would say
the 30s with Roosevelt was the first
crack in that Republican armor and with
blacks kind of testing out the
Democratic Party but the Democratic
Party was very racist in those days in
terms of being overtly racist right you
know dixiecrats and some of those people
they weren't kidding around you know so
that was
a lot for you no backs to say they were
Democrats in those days but there were
the democratic political parties for I
think more big 10 Tisch in those days
too like you had conservative
Republicans but you have moderate
Republicans you actually have liberal
Republicans in those days you know you
had those Dixiecrat Democrats you have
progressive Democrats you know they're
both parties actually had a lot of
different factions in them that don't
quite exist today
and depending on the time period I think
certain factions have more power or more
influence depending on the time period
you know like the Republicans were very
progressive during Teddy Roosevelt's
time we were a very big business during
Calvin Coolidge you know very few short
years later you know that's saying that
the contradictory butts where the
emphasis is being placed right so it was
the 1950s it's interesting 1950s was the
last time that Republicans may have had
a majority support in the black humanity
remember Eisenhower was the one who sent
the troops to was there Arkansas yeah
I'm not sure yellow ring even though I
think Truman desegregated the army
military correct I believe so yeah
but it wasn't considered a bad thing to
be a Republican Martin Luther King's
father was a Republican in fact you know
but I believe it was the Kennedy Nixon
election and then it was the Johnson
administration that got the blacks if
you look at this as a team sport you
know that black people said wait I don't
think the Lakers are doing it over here
I'm gonna go to the Clippers zero and
the black people I think in large parts
switched teams based on what happened
politically in the 1960s and I think if
you look at history it takes a long time
to change people's minds on those things
I think it really does and even though
some of the anecdotal opinions in it and
some of the observations on it aren't
wrong we're people don't quite operate
that way I think when you look at human
nature and this specific experience of
black people in America that's the best
way I can describe that so for me I
don't have an observation and I try to
look at these things differently that
one side is right or wrong and that
because there's a lot of things that are
completely true in that and by the way
many black people socially for many
years have been conservative right you
know and then it's hop ain't only passed
in California because Barack Obama was
on the ballot correct
one of the few groups that are arguably
are more conservative but who vote
liberal yes right in terms of the group
of people you know so I really think it
comes down to more of a team thing now
having said that you get people who
bristle when you're on the wrong team
and I think that's where a lot of that
comes from you know it's the best way
that I can put it you know I feel a lot
of bit of silly personally so but I
understand it cuz I've been called those
things myself you know for different
reasons I know how how that feels you
know and that sort of thing so I want to
talk about the comedy side now so sure
so obviously you spent this having funny
guys can we go to another commercial no
not yet sorry they're there more coming
oh we have to monetize you to the
fullest possible job yeah but let's
let's talk about you know the comedic
world so sure I'm gonna give you the
conservative critique of the comedic
world you're yes I've heard some of your
critique I am sure you have so I I did
one just just a couple of days ago and
Stephen Colbert so you can I ask you a
question offshore why do you have a
conservative critique comedy like why is
there conservative critique I think when
you hear the critique you'll understand
the critique is that today's comedy has
become politically one-sided that's the
conservative critique okay but if you
look at late night
what you're seeing is Jimmy Kimmel who I
have I will I will say I have used the
term woke Pope to describe him that
here's the the Pope of the man show he
did start on the man show but he's come
a long way since his roots yeah since he
was doing bouncing boobs out with with
Adam Carolla and and and then you've got
Jimmy Fallon who's basically been
excoriated for the great Center of
touching Donald Trump's hair and then
you have though feminism he's not in the
category there done you know he's sort
of moved political after that happened
specifically I mean he had to come out
here to apologize for and all this kind
of stuff and then you have Colbert who's
obviously very loud and proud right very
much to the Latin huh
for years did a Bill O'Reilly routine
and to mock him and and all of that and
so a lot of conservatives look at the
comedic world and they say why is this
so one-sided why isn't there like
they'll even look back fondly to Jay
Leno and Johnny Carson and say at least
these guys made jokes about both sides
sure and you know as a conservative I
can say that when I watch a lot of these
shows I feel the same way I look at them
and I say no one made a joke about
Barack Obama for eight years now that I
agree with you
I talked about this very recently the
Obama part and I felt that first of all
white comedians especially comedians
definitely on the left were afraid of
making the wrong joke about Obama and
when they did make jokes about Obama
they were flattering jokes you know like
nobody really made real observational
jokes about Obama that's why the
impressions of Obama weren't that good
because nobody's making really good
observations about him you know
and some said well what about the angry
translators that that is that is an
observation on black culture not really
about Obama and was flattering to Obama
the whole thing was Obama's so
self-control was so boys did which is
fine and I it was funny but I mean that
was people were so precious with them
and I wish there was more of that you
know because to me that's part of a
comedian's job now the other part of it
I believe we're in a cycle a lot of
these things go in cycles and I think
what's popular now is that it's kind of
maybe the Jon Stewart effect because
John was John was just very good yeah
he's but remember John didn't nobody was
doing that you know we did it on my show
the nightly show gonna with with that
approach and John Oliver certainly in
his show but um you know I think these
things go in cycles and them markets and
I I feel you know when you feel like
you're on the outside of it how come I
can't be in on the joke but I don't
think all of it is like that I think
Saturday Night Live really tries it's
best to be fair in that way and you know
as much as they can and they've gotten
criticized for for some of that you know
and by fair I mean really trying to poke
holes at both sides you know but I think
a lot of it is driven by the marketplace
whom what seems to be popular and that
sort of thing as well as that's what you
know someone like Colbert that's what he
wants to do and that's what he wants to
talk about as well
both of those things I know I mean that
the zeitgeist can be very picky the
zeitgeist can turn in your name own so
one thing I learned about showbiz two
years from now maybe having a different
conversation what happened to all those
political comedians and I wonder if the
zeitgeist is moving against comedy
generally so one of the things that I've
noticed and commented on is I saw Hannah
Gadsby special not a fan and and one of
the things that I saw is the critics
basically saying that Hannah Gadsby
shouldn't make you laugh but you make
you think and it was a new kind of
comedy and so it seemed as though she
was moving for what I my show I call
clapped her it wasn't it wasn't really
for laughs it was it was more for oh
that's amazing enough
you know and sort of a sympathetic
laughter as opposed to the laughter of
recognition of a reality which is
usually the best kind of comedy in in my
under observing opinion
it's tough to say BIM because many times
these kind of critiques are resisting
something as well you know because
sometimes these critiques are people
want something to be like what they've
seen already you know and many times
when you're doing something new people
don't like it because it's different and
it doesn't conform to rules that they
like I'm happy with these rules why are
you doing something different you know
and so I think a lot of critiques are
born out of that like to me I'm like
she's who cares if she does something
different there's a lot of other comics
out there you know
oh no they listen she more power to her
I mean I'm happy for her that she's
she's earning wealth and fame overnight
but the the redefinition by critics of
comedy itself in order to meet somebody
who they agree with politically I find
troubling simply because it used to be
that you would watch something he was
either funny or it was not funny like I
could acknowledge the John Stewart I
could who I disagree with politically is
a deeply funny human being I mean he's
really funny right but you may not laugh
if you don't agree and that's what the
clap that comes in look Tina Fey used
the same term by the way she was she was
making her same observation years ago
but people because they get last with
that those are laughs you know people do
think it's funny now you can say yes but
it's a green funny which is also true
but that's what they're doing I just
wonder if we're moving away from a time
when people can make even most kinds of
jokes so the Seinfeld refuses to go on
college campuses now because he's afraid
of being shouted down right you make
certain kind of jokes and YouTube will
to monetize you it depends on on the
kind of joke I the other night my wife
and I made the mistake of watching
airplane again and airplane is a very
funny movie but it's a time-bound movie
like you watch it now and you can watch
it sort of in the privacy of your own
home looking around to make sure that
nobody's watching no no absolutely we
did I did a show called the PJs years
ago as an animated show that any Murphy
it was like claymation type of thing and
we did a joke on there with this
observation 20 years ago where they're
good the head of the projects he finds
one of Richard Pryor's old albums and
it's like that n-word is crazy and you
say and they're like super can we put
into play it you can't even say this
anymore
joke so believe me this is something
that's been happening over a long period
I mean are you worried about that
because I've always been worried about
that but I realized in some ways there's
nothing I can do about it
look I ran into this in the early 90s I
took a little bit about this in the
power we're you know another comic kind
of shut me down not airing something
because didn't agree with what I was
saying you know and to me that was like
how is she making assault on speech you
know what's going on here why are we
being presage precious about this ABC
just the other night aired you know
their tribute to all on the family in
the Jefferson right you know and they
actually bleeped a couple of words that
weren't bleeped back in the day there's
no oil in the family makes the air today
it's Renee just know why saying you know
so this is this cultural shift has been
happening for a long time I blame it all
on Alf a man came on in the 80s changed
everything a little bit I mean he
literally is in it legally so in a
second I want to ask you a little bit
more about the comedic world then I want
to get to a tripartite distinction about
politics I heard you make it on your
podcast that I think is really break
down the 2020 race in a second but first
with the ever increasing number of car
makes and models it's pretty much
impossible to stock all the parts you
need in a traditional chain store front
why endure the often pointless or
seemingly intimidating questioning like
is your Odyssey and LX and EX I don't
even know the answer to that wait while
the counterman orders the parts on his
computer and then chooses the only brand
his warehouse happens to carry you have
computers with access to the internet
with access to Rock Auto calm at home
and in your pocket Rock Auto calm it's a
family business serving Auto Parts
customers online for 20 years Kota RAC
Auto comm shop for auto and body parts
from hundreds of manufacturers they have
everything you need from engine control
modules and brake parts to tail lamps
motor oil even new carpet whether it's
for your classic or daily driver get
everything you need in a few easy clicks
delivered directly to your door the Rock
auto comm catalog it's unique it's
remarkably easy to navigate quickly see
all the parts available for your vehicle
choose the brands specifications and
prices you prefer best of all prices at
rockauto.com
are always reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers they
have an amazing selection reliably low
prices what do you have to lose check
out Rock Auto calm go to rock Auto calm
right now see all the parts available
for
or car or truck right Shapiro in there
how did you hear about us box so they
know that we sent you so you know going
back to sort of this comedic distinction
one of the things that I find you know
difficult is that it's also it's reached
into the issue of politics it crosses
all boundaries it feels like they're two
things have happened one you can't have
open conversations with people anymore
because if you do you might violate some
unspoken rule which means that you must
be ousted from the Overton Window and
then observation number two is that our
common spaces seem to have sort of
disappeared where we could sort of all
agree before okay there was at least
something that was funny right we
disagree on politics but we can all go
to this movie in this movie is just
funny and there's nothing wrong with the
movie just being funny right now we have
to load it up with with all of the
proper messaging and if it doesn't carry
the messaging then it is retrograde then
it is ripped down for being retrograde
and and maybe it has to be silenced
maybe it's offensive to somebody and it
feels like the conversation is becoming
narrower I'm fine with people becoming
more sensitive I mean like that I'm okay
with but I but I don't know but I guess
more sensitive to others I don't think
more sensitive to their own concerns
like I like me being more sensitive to
something somebody else feels I'm okay
with that
so long as it doesn't require me to
speak falsehood but me being more
sensitive to my own concerns I mean man
up get get over at like baby it and it's
all me this is you know I didn't give
you one of these leftist years hot or
cold tongue but no the fact is I would
know it so I wouldn't consider you a
leftist I mean the distinction I've made
a thousand times between leftist and
liberal a liberal is somebody who
disagrees with me on tax rates and
government involvement but also agrees
that we have to have some interesting
wide-ranging conversation the leftist is
somebody who wants to get media
monetized I would be called the classic
liberal in my beliefs yeah so so you
know where do you think we're going I
mean is it possible I don't know if I
agree with your premise completely like
for instance if you look at a lot of the
stuff Disney puts out like the Pixar
movies I think are fantastic you know
and I don't think they're preaching like
in that sort of way they were talking
about you know and I think they're made
for the entire family in fact it's kind
of one of their missions you know to do
that sort of thing like Toy Story that
last toy story you know that simple
story of that kid going off to school I
mean it broke my heart you know and was
so funny and all that kind of stuff you
know things like The Incredibles look at
me and one of my pushing Disney's
company then
but I think there is a lot of content
like that but but you're right when a
lot of the noise goes to the other but I
I say that's what's in the zeitgeist
right now and that's why but as I said
the zeitgeist can be very picky but when
something's getting attention it's what
we pay attention to the most you know so
look now let's talk a little bit about
president Trump's we've avoid yes he
word the entire podcast up to this point
mainly because I um I don't how much you
love Trump that's it you know he's my
cam that's the only thing I president
Jam sounds disgusting about it I it
would be I can't get that image out of
my head of marmalade
I think that's terrible I think it would
be very Marmee thank you so much for
that it sounds horrific but yes no I
can't not can't stop thinking about it's
like don't think of an elephant thank
you yeah thank you so so let's talk
about president Trump so I didn't vote
as you know for president Trump in 2016
I am much more likely as I've said to
vote for President Trump in 2020 spoiler
alert I didn't and probably won't either
yeah so what do you make of sort of what
brought Trump about and and you said
that you think the Trump is gonna get
reelected yeah only 20 it's my
unfortunate prediction but I also
predicted he'd be elected in the last
election unfortunately well your record
on it I like them pretty much Baron Milo
and grant unless I was very mad at my
prediction by the way you know I
remember being shouted down on my own
show about it but to me it was part of
what you were talking about earlier it's
what he was connecting to you know and I
think what Trump does well is he sells
his own brand and I thought he did that
well even though I think his brand it's
very messy and you know here's where
Trump turned me off in the beginning and
I couldn't believe that he kept going
was in that first interview where he
first slammed John McCain you know
though I'm talking about
ever you talk about I would like my
heroes who aren't cut or something like
that I could not believe he said that
especially that is such a canceling
thing for for someone running for
president particularly a Republican you
know and I could not believe that the
Republicans didn't cancel him for that
that he wasn't cancelled and I was
shocked by that
and that moment alone meant a lot to
message something else is going on here
if he's not cancelled for that what are
we watching you know and so I watched it
kind of a
fring hi and then just saying he's
horrible or he's not this or that you
know I was trying to watch it almost as
a phenomena of something happening I
remember the second thing was during the
first debate where the way that he let's
say dealt with megyn kelly you know he
was completely disrespectful he was
throwing you know just bombs her and
everything hit the people who liked him
loved the fact that he would do that and
would not be Precious about that in any
way and I saw that look when he called
Rosie O'Donnell Pig I think you said
that and when that got applause and not
like derision I was like okay he's
winning he is winning you know and the
way he systematically almost like a you
know just song with a surgical knife
just talk about heart like from Jeb to
Marco to those people was fascinating I
couldn't believe it I I wasn't sure I
was hoping my prediction would be wrong
that he still would not beat Hillary
Clinton
I felt was as like as she was from both
sides was still a very formidable
opponent you know which the fact that
she wanted more actual votes in him even
proves that point so to me I thought he
tapped into many different things and
I've written about some of this but I
did think he tapped into an anger you
know and their people have many
different opinions of what people are
angry about but I'll just call it that
people were angry and that Trump
represented them in a way that they felt
other people weren't carrying the bucket
for that anger and that he would happily
carry that bucket whether it was their
anger about immigration whether it was
about you know I don't know if they were
angry about trade but certainly about
you know wages are that sort of thing I
think they felt Trump was the only one
who carried the bucket and minted to
that's what I saw in there yeah I mean
my take is that a lot of the Trump
phenomenon can was and continues to be a
rebellion specifically to pop culture
possible though because the left is so
dominant in terms of partner but that
the right has responded by saying we
have no power in the cultural sphere
yeah and so we're gonna respond with the
political sphere but we have to but
truck like if from snot a celebrity he's
not the president right the fact the
fact that he was at right the fact that
he was a celebrity is a reason because
for a lot of Republicans the idea that
somebody who's a celebrity even a dr8
celebrity as Trump was by the time he
ran I mean
ten he's an a rate celebrity by 2016 is
ad rate but but for Republicans it was
like wow a celebrity who's not crapping
on us this is incredible yeah and you
got that feeling from a lot of people
like he was sort of the legitimation of
them in the culture here's what I'll
disagree with you that I don't think
it's a bad observation as to why a lot
of people like him but I don't think
it's why they voted for him I really
think he came out in his first speech
about immigration and the way he talked
about how the country is being invaded
and that he would build a wall and I
think he brought a lot of that from an
culture and from her book but those are
the magic phrases that energize people
to vote for him which I believe is
different than liking somebody to
actually vote for somebody I believe was
different I don't disagree with you of
why they like him but I think why they
voted from started with that in that
policy and that by the way is his most
divisive policy even with his base and I
talked about this a little bit when I
said that's the when he said Mexico's
didn't pay for it he was baby was
when he says that but he's
being completely honest when he talks
about what he views as the problem in
America that it's being invaded and the
people who relate to that statement are
not going anywhere in terms of being his
base and that's why they pulled that
lever from my point of view I think the
the pop stuff it's interesting but I
don't think that's why that base is
strong you know no I think there's I
think there's a lot of truth that this
one starts with immigration
yeah yeah certainly there are a lot of
folks who grew the including ankles all
right who says he doesn't build the wall
he's lately they're willing to run away
because of that issue not because of
trade you know trades hurting a lot of
people that voted for Trump you know not
because not for how he appears on the
world stage which both sides have
disagreements about that and he's been
blasted you know particularly by his own
party even right now you know people you
know the problem practice upset over a
lot of things he's done especially with
Mexico in these tariffs and everything
but people aren't leaving them because
that the only reason why people would
abandon him is over immigration and
building law which is fascinating anyway
so this brings me to the the tripart
distinction that you sort of hit on a
little bit there but I wanted you to
explicate it for folks who haven't heard
your podcast which you should go listen
to the Larry Larry Wilmore show back on
the air back on the air there's a
commercial but
you made a distinction the other week
that I thought was really good and
fascinating because it does get to the
heart of
what is happening in politics generally
and that was this this tripartite
distinction between bullying honesty and
truth telling and you sort of rank
presidents along lines if not and you
know and you I haven't heard the podcast
yet where you rank the current
candidates along those lines yes I
started with some of them but I have a
feeling that that you know that may
carrying into why you think he's gonna
win in 2020 yes so I was making a
distinction I was using I was talking
about my Lakers of Magic Johnson I was
so upset because I felt magic he talks
about how much he loves the Lakers on
all this stuff and then he was he was
telling us this lurid story of what
happened we having scenes if he was
backstabbed how Genie is running the
company right and then he tells us how
much he loves the Lakers I'm like and
people are like well it's so brave that
magic told the truth magic and tell the
truth magic was being honest he was
focusing on his feelings and you know
how he felt about this situation that he
was backstabbed in all this but the
truth of the matter was magic was there
part-time you know and there Rob Kalinka
wasn't wrong you know in that you know
people should be upset about that but
you know honesty was what he was focused
on and I think our society because we're
selling over feelings these days I think
there's such an over a I think there's
too much interest in people's feelings
these days it's one of the things I've
talked about for actually a long time
and not enough for people's actions you
know and I'm one of those actions over
feelings type persons and have been for
a very long time but I think what
honesty represents is how you feel about
something primarily honesty's about you
the truth teller is different telling
the truth many times there's nothing to
do with you might be completely against
what you actually want or what you stand
for you know but the interest is in
telling something outside of yourself
that represents an actual thing you know
the actual event or whatever it is and
then both I was making a political
distinction about I was talking about
politics in particular how people are
actually trying to sell you something
yeah really you know it's all about
whatever it is that they're trying to
sell you or that type of thing you know
I can't learn the exact words I use but
I was talking about politicians in how
they occur and I was saying Trump's base
like them because they view that he is
honest he's being honest them and I said
and I agree with him
I believe Trump is an honest huckster I
really do I think he was very honest in
terms of wanting to sell the Trump brand
first of all he's very honest
how he feels about alien invasion is how
he puts it in the country I think he's
an honest purveyor of that but he's not
a truth teller he's not telling the
truth about situations I don't know if
Trump's ever told the truth about
situation by the way but another one of
his with let's call it gifts because
I'll put these in the political realm is
his ability to but he's very
good about that
now most people are used to politicians
because that's the tool they've
use forever so the people that really
love Trump don't necessarily like his
bull you know and so like when Trump
let's talk about immigration when he
talks about you know rapist to come in
here and blah blah blah where he's being
honest about how it really feels about
it that's what people connect to no one
would say what Trump just said you know
he's being so honest right
they pot him because they feel no one
would say that and it's and he's doing
an act of honesty when he says Mexico
pay for it that's both no and that's the
part that they're frustrated about uh
why does he say this you know this is
both because now he has to actually sell
this thing that he was honest about you
know so I was kind of giving I guess him
credit for that and making observation
between the net out occurs even though
it feels like an oxymoron I believe
that's how it occurs in politicians and
I was going through some of the list of
presidents and that who I thought who
were honest two or more truth tellers
you know and I put both in there to sell
well who do you think is capable of
beating him on the Democratic side since
you think that he's well I don't know if
anybody else I mean right now it I mean
we're so early Biden is the only one
possibly I think who has a chance just
because of name recognition and as you
say because of popularity because people
know who you are I think that goes a
long way in America biking is primarily
a bullshitter though my point of view I
don't know if he's very honest even and
I think people discredit or prevent I
mean the whole plagiarism things an
example that and I believe he has been a
bit of a truth teller sometimes but not
enough to make that a distinguishing
issue that's where he got in trouble
with the crime bill and that sort of
thing even though he's being very
political with that as well I think you
know but as we know that's a politician
too that's kind of what they do best is
the most part so that's why I think he
probably is in the front right now but
we'll see as we as you know I mean this
time during 2008 I'm
about work 2007 whatever was Obama's
sofa nobody thought Obama had a chance
you know even firing to the debates like
many black people weren't supporting
Obama yet because they thought he didn't
have a chance it's when he took Iowa
where he got a lot of the black support
from Philly
felt that he had a chance there's one
thing about these presidential elections
that I always find interesting is that
it can change so PEZ McCain McCain was
right in Southwest Airlines you know in
2007 people thought he was out of it
Liberty Leon it was gonna be me and
Larry at that point you know and McCain
had this surge i was unbelievable you
know and became the front-runner i mean
one of the things that's fascinating to
watch actually if you in the democratic
polls this is the huge share of the
black vote that biden is getting right
now in the polling where it obviously is
an aftereffect of broccoli agreement
that complete and the fact that Kamala
Harris is drawing flies and and Cory
Booker is drawing flies is already
telling I think Cory Booker will
continue to draw flies I don't know if
the same thing is true about Camilla
Harris Cory Booker yeah both Cory Booker
he's maybe made one he's he's one of the
chief ones I agree with that but Connell
Harris is a sneaky one she's a sneaky
builder because she's very talented
politically and I think she's should I
have an interesting career I don't know
if she's running for president at the
right time you know she it may be
premature for her in terms of strategy
you're talking about not in terms of
being able to do it because the field is
so crowded and everything I don't know
she can cut through all that but um but
I think she's much more talented than
Cory but she's she's a bit of a boss do
you know but I think you know when you
come from that when you're a DA and that
type of thing I don't know it always
feels like those kind of jobs there's a
little bit of that in there anyway some
so in a second I want to ask you the
final question which will be you know
what do you think the future of the
country is given all the problems that
we've talked about and some of the lack
of discourse civil discourse that's
happening right now if you want to hear
larry wilmore's answer you have to be a
daily water subscriber you have to give
us your money to subscribe head on over
to daily we're calm click subscribe you
can hear the end of our conversation
there right Larry I really appreciate it
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producer Mathis Glover edited by Donovan
Fowler audio is mixed by Mike Kamino
hair and makeup is by Jesuit alvera
title graphics by Cynthia Angulo the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
[Music]